We learned in the videos on
torque that torque equals--
let me actually draw a picture,
so you remember what
we're talking about
with torque.
So let's say-- so that's the
arm, let's say right here is
what its pivot is.
That's its pivot.
And let's say that I'm putting
a force right there, and it's
perpendicular to this arm.
And let's say the length
of this arm is r.
And this force is f.
So we know that the torque
is this force times
the distance, right?
And then we also know that--
what is force?
Well, that is equal
to mass times
acceleration times distance.
So torque is equal
to mass times
acceleration times distance.
And then so what is
acceleration?
Well that's equal to mass times
change in velocity over
change in time, times
distance, right?
So we learned all that from our
torque chapter, and you
might want to review it, just
to get an intuition of what
torque is good for.
But in general, if something
isn't spinning, you apply
torque, and you'll
get it spinning.
Or if something is spinning
already, if you apply torque
in the direction that it's
spinning, it'll spin faster.
Or if you go in the opposite
direction, it'll spin slower.
And what I'm showing you here,
is that what happens if you
apply no torque?
Well if you apply no torque,
then we know that this
quantity is 0.
Or another way to think about
it-- actually why did I write
d, it could be d, but I
shouldn't have called this r,
it should be d.
So if this is 0-- if we are
applying no torque, right--
what do we know?
We know that the change in
velocity over change in time,
times this distance,
won't change-- that
this quantity is 0.
So we know that the velocity
times the distance is going to
be a constant.
And that comes from what
I just talked about.
It falls out of Newton's laws,
but it applies to spinning.
An object that's not spinning
will tend to not stay
spinning, and an object
that is spinning will
tend to stay spinning.
So in this case, if this object
at this point right
here-- so we're in a case where
there's no torque, so
this force is 0-- there's
no force applying here.
And whatever this object's
velocity was-- its tangential
velocity-- it's going to stay
at that velocity, right?
It's just going to keep spinning
at that velocity.
If I apply more torque it'll
go even faster, if I apply
less torque, it'll slow
down a little bit.
But we know that this
velocity times
the distance is constant.
And actually, I don't know why
I took this m out-- we know
that the mass times the velocity
times the distance,
is constant.
Right?
So what does that tell us?
Well, we learned in the angular
velocity video-- my
mind's a little slow
today-- that what?
Angular velocity is equal to
velocity divided by the
radius, and this case, the
radius is this distance, so we
could also write it as velocity
over distance.
And when I talk about radius,
it's just the radius of the
circle that you're spinning
around in, right?
This could be the
circle, up here.
So this d, that's the same
thing as the radius.
I'm just switching letters
to confuse you.
But let's see if we can write
something, if we can change
this expression to include
angular velocity.
You'll see where I'm
going in a second.
So let's solve for v.
So let's multiply both sides
of this, times d.
So you get dw is equal to v.
Right, I just took this d,
put it on this side.
So let's write that here-- m
times dw-- right, I just
replaced the v-- times d,
is equal to a constant.
Assuming that we have no net
torque on the system.
And so what does that get us?
Well that gets us m times the
angular velocity times d
squared is equal
to a constant.
So what does this tell us?
This tells us the mass of an
object spinning-- let me
rewrite this, because I think--
so what we know is
that the mass of an object
spinning, times how fast it is
spinning, times the distance
to the center of its
rotation-- and actually I'm
going to change that d to an
r, I don't know why I even used
d to begin with-- times
that squared.
That's going to be equal to a
constant, assuming no net
force-- no net torque.
Another way of looking at that,
if we just wanted to go
to angular velocity from the
get-go, we could have said
torque is equal to mass times
change in velocity, times
change in time, times the radius
to the center of where
you're rotating around.
And change in velocity is just
the same thing as mass times
change in angular velocity,
times r.
Change in time, and then
there's another
r, that's this r.
Because velocity is angular
velocity times r, and we're
assuming r doesn't change, so
any change in velocity is just
going to be a change in
the angular velocity.
And then we would get the same
thing that we just got here.
If we have no net torque, we're
going to have no change
in angular velocity, so angular
velocity will be a constant.
So you'll get mass times angular
velocity, times-- and
then you have this r, and this
r-- times r squared, is going
to be equal to a constant.
Where am I going with
all of this?
Well let's think about
something.
Let's say that I have some
object traveling in a circle.
I do everything for a reason,
and you'll see my
reason right now.
Let's say that-- so let's
say this is some type of
retractable pole, and
I'm an ice skater.
And I'm not using the ice
skater's body right now,
because it'll become
complicated.
Let's say this is some type of
robot arm, and that's its
joint right there.
And it's holding a
mass out here.
This is neat because after
this concept, you'll
understand what goes on in
figure skating, and then the
Olympics-- oh no, the
Winter Olympics are
over, aren't they?
Anyway, let's say that this
object is spinning
around at some rate.
It's spinning around at
10 radians a second.
That's its angular velocity.
And let's say, right
now its rotational
distance is 10 feet.
So this is spinning on an ice
skating rink, because you
don't want friction
and all of that.
So what's its current
angular momentum?
So that's what this term right
here is, angular momentum.
So what's its current
angular momentum?
Well its mass times 10, times--
10 is its-- actually,
let's make this radius a
different number, let's call
it 8 feet, just you know
what I'm doing.
So its angular velocity is
10, and then its radius
is 8, so times 64.
So it equals 640 times mass.
This is its angular momentum.
Now what happens if this arm,
for whatever reason,
shortens-- and maybe it does
something like this, the arm
kind of bends.
And then the mass comes
here, it comes in
closer to the center.
I'll write that in a
different color.
The mass comes closer to
the center, so now
the radius is 4.
But I've had no net torque on
the system, all I've done is
change how far it is from
the center of rotation.
How much faster is it
going to spin now?
Let's think about it.
Its angular momentum won't
change, this is a constant,
which is its angular momentum.
That won't change.
So we now know that the mass
times the angular-- the new
angular momentum, we'll write
that angular momentum 1--
times the new distance squared--
times 16-- is also
going to be equal to 640m.
The angular momentum
doesn't change.
Let's cross out m from both
sides, and then divide both
sides by 16.
We now have that w1 is equal
to 16 goes into 640.
So what happened?
Originally, I was going around
at 10 radians per second, when
I halved the radius-- when I
got half as close to the
center of my rotation, I'm
actually spinning around 4
times as much.
And that's because this term
is a quadratic term.
And you probably have observed
this behavior before, when you
see the ice skater skating
around, and they're spinning
with their arms wide open, and
then they pull their arms in,
and they go a lot, lot,
lot, lot faster.
And that's because their angular
velocity, or the rate
at which they're spinning, is
proportional to the square of
the radius around their
axis of rotation.
Anyway, I hope I didn't confuse
you, and I'll do some
more problems with this in
the future, but I've
just run out of time.
See you soon.